hello thank you for watching I'm sure we
can't be that long first of all I must
apologize I believe your name is Tasha
Dean Ward I had used Miss Dean so
apologies Miss Wood
um I'd like to correct that okay
following consideration by the committee
we've decided to run the application
under the amended operating schedule
and external hours for music
that said it is noted that through noise
in your noise and management plan I aim
for 75 decibels is clearly stated at the
at the back and when we're monitored by
you on site we'd like that to continue
and be rigorous about it please
it's just appropriate that the venue are
now reaching out to Residents and we
encourage that however the residents do
have recourse back to the council should
the noise management plan not be a
solution
the guys that knowledge the contact
number is available to Residents and we
would expect that that number is
available at all events outside of all
times
we also know the venue moving away from
previous style of events and again our
reiterate
the residents do have a right to request
a review of the license
should persistent nuisance
occur however the committee are
quite satisfied that the
structures put in place will and
the problematic noise over on your side
okay
thank you very much thank you all for
your intrusion uh in in your the words
gone your input and
thank you very much